John is living in Manhattan right now
uh-huh I got out of Manhattan you got
out of Manhattan but he went out to walk
his dog come over and start petting the
dog right John so I have a cute little
white dog and people and she's very
friendly and rambunctious and people
want to pet her and come over to her and
it's like no no no we gotta keep our
distance here it drives me nuts our
why'd you shave your head what was that
about
let's get along my wife likes my hair
short and so why not what else are we
doing right now so I I went and
attempted it and let's just say I needed
help from my wife and my daughter before
because it looked like a complete mess
oh I thought you shaved your hairs like
it's like who would come within six feet
of John with that shaved head you know I
mean what are you doing Manhattan when
you got to go down the elevator like
aren't there other people in the
elevator
no well I will not get on an elevator if
somebody else is on it and actually
treated people have always treated me
that way when it comes to an elevator if
I'm in it they won't come on but it's
very like you'll wait the extra five
minutes it's okay and I have either I
have the bag to pick up my dogs poop in
it and I will use the bag beforehand to
press the buttons and but when you're in
the elevator you're just thinking oh no
who was in this elevator like you know
right love very people go up people in
my building I know have it so we're all
living in fear it's it's scary I didn't
know you played guitar when did that
happen because someone told me you're
not a guitar oh I've always played like
a little bit and my wife actually
suggested she's like you should break
out the guitar and and I did and my
daughter plays so we were going back and
forth and it's it was a fun you know it
was a fun thing to do we when Kenny
Rogers passed away we actually had a
little Kenny Rogers sing-along to remind
us of all the good tunes even though I
was horrible playing them can't say I
can't wait to hear I can't wait for you
to debut your guitar work on honey air
here
wouldn't you love to be at John's house
for the sing-along I'll zoom to you
Robin and you can even chime in
you